Here We Go Again yard
bird
10.5 out of 22 I'm on minus one after
games with one draw 10 wins 11 losses
one
draw yeah yeah
yeah always a big fight against him yeah
E4 or E3 H like both
yeah let's do
E3 and Knight
E2 completing
development so what am I doing here
maybe this
one making sure I control
G4 um is F4 an idea here or is
it is it bad H hard to say
I'd actually like to to grab the space
to be honest it looks like a loss of a
Tempo but it's not that important in the
meantime he had put his Knight on C7
which is
also maybe not the best ever
position his setup with the n on C7 was
more geared towards playing E4 and D5 so
if I go E4 myself this is probably okay
strategically speaking
he can hardly take
now I wonder if I really will play yeah
I was just thinking about this move if
this is uh if this is any good or not C5
yeah looks like the normal
reaction C5 but after taking here
B C5 B4 takes on D6 but I can just put
the
Knight um
somewhere it's got Bishop A6
maybe yeah that's still the right move
whatever okay he's not going for that
he's going for for that type of stuff
here I was thinking that F4 should be
good for me
F4 taking this big
space Maybe not maybe
not E5 Knight D5
okay um Queen
E3 B3
yeah or or F5 yeah something different
trying
to and then he's got B4 and really has
this
pressure
H so Queen E3 and then that's Knight D5
all the
time okay probably have to do
that okay what now B3 here maybe has
F6 okay I want I want to do I want to be
sure that after C4 I can take
not give him this perfect
structure
true true that's a good
Square H that's not looking
good really
not
um this just terrible in the
position just just totally
terrible
wow so C5 wasn't working at all it
seems
weird my idea is
to force through a knight to D6 yeah and
um trying to to to drum up some sort of
play but definitely this is not nothing
that is sufficient that's
clear maybe F5
F6 full scale swindling mode
here it takes then
F5
wow that's amazingly bad this
position that's always Knight F4 even
what what what how bad is that
okay after the capture I want to play F5
but it's it's
nothing it just lost
him
wow and the problem was this instant
pressure on e4 so that I felt obliged to
play
E5
H amazing how quickly this this went
went
downhill
Rook
F5 Rook F5 of course very
simple yeah but it was lost anyway and
nothing nothing to do here total
disaster game
now what is he trying to do rub it in or
what Rook F5 he's seeing
that definitely is no he's not
okay yeah this wins as
well
keeping G3 protected
but check it's not really helping me
much oh
wow
okay Rook H uh three amongst
others Queen H3 maybe as
well
check yeah Rook F2 is
made
Rook F2 is just a
m
check
check this this is well
unfortunately
okay yeah this was an opening opening
disaster of great
magnitude okay well this is a totally
normal position of
course and C5 is kind of the normal way
to play this this
structure but it just didn't work here I
guess because of the direct pressure on
E5 the position got downhill super
quickly after that it's really
completely due to the opening yeah maybe
I should just take I
mean something something like that is
just just a normal
position where you can argue is this
slightly better for white is it equal I
don't know but um
yeah this is amazing how quick how
quickly it it it is going down here the
problem is this pressure on four this is
the real
problem I went here here and now I
played e
five and he got D5
yeah um maybe I need to improve right
here to even retain a playable position
the problem was that this wasn't even
playable after that I'm basically lost
yeah Bishop F5 was uh was very
strong I probably have to play
this it's clearly not convincing but I
probably have to to do
it he simply now has this this great
piece yeah this is what I need to do I
mean and try to go from here but I'm a
pawn down and this is not a good
compensation yeah here I'm lost yeah I
just I mean he um I think he never
really let me back into the game even
though there maybe were quicker quicker
ways to
win uh like uh like Rook F5 here this is
this was the the the easiest way but
okay this is of course totally lost I'm
just going through because it's funny to
see that stock which is on minus 15 and
stuff like
that there were some checkmates that he
didn't didn't play for some reason so C5
was really
bogus
huh
yeah now I have to take there's no way
around it this is this is this is okay
nothing out of the out of the
ordinary okay wow thanks for
watching